MIKE: We're here with
Mickey and Isaac in Indiana.
It has been a tough day so far.
We're really having
to dig to find stuff
they're willing to let go.
Champion spark plugs.
MICKEY: I guess I was a little
surprised about how much he
wanted that sign off the wall.
ISAAC: He worked
at it real hard.
MICKEY: There you go.
Well, hey.
So after all that
work, I finally
get something that I think
has absolutely no attachment.
Would you guys
consider selling this?
It's not in the
best condition, but
still it's automotive related.
MICKEY: Probably not.
MIKE: And I was wrong.
And I was wrong over
and over and over again.
It's just advertisement
for the shop.
- Yeah.
- It told what we done here.
Yeah, there's tons
of history you guys
have in here for the wagons.
Right.
But not really too
much for the cars.
Yeah.
Not too much for the cars and
what we done to them here.
Imagine that.
You know, right there.
MICKEY: We sold
automotive accessories.
And it was a sign
that they could've
put out front, at one
time, and said hey,
we got your spark plugs here.
Going in the
blacksmith's shop,
I remember a lot of things that
went on here when I was a kid.
My grandpa was a blacksmith.
My great grandpa
was a blacksmith.
MIKE: Oh.
This place is incredible.
Wow.
The smell, the sounds.
MICKEY: You just don't see a
lot of old blacksmith shops
anymore.
This is still original.
There's no way you can
prepare yourself for it.
I mean, walking
back into this room.
MICKEY: It's like
walking back in time.
MIKE: I mean, it
truly is. truly is.
ISAAC: It is walking
back in time.
MIKE: All old buildings
have personality.
They're all different
in some way or another.
They're like people.
It's so cool.
So this was
basically his office?
I mean, this I can see
was mounted right to here.
This was his writing desk.
You know, he had all his
paperwork inside of there.
And then he had all
of this cabinetry
for every single thing
that he would need.
You got large doors here.
You got large doors
back there and here.
It's like air coming through
as much as it possibly can.
This had to be the
busiest place in town.
[music playing]
FRANK: What's up, John Lennon?
ISAAC: Yeah, there you go.
What about that?
This is a sign bracket.
MICKEY: Yeah, it is a sign.
And they probably made it here.
MIKE: Nah, I doubt it.
I've seen a lot of these.
This would be for a round sign.
Something that was double sided.
$75.
- $90 Let's do the dance.
- I'll do it.
I got a round sign.
To me, I want something to
look like it has history.
It has miles on it.
That's exactly what
this piece has.
It's an awesome piece.
So Speedwagon.
REO?
MIKE: No.
Well, yeah, REO Speedwagon.
That was actually a vehicle.
Way before REO Speedwagon
topped the charts with "Keep
on Loving You," REO Speedwagon
was a light duty truck
that was manufactured by
the REO Motor Car Company
in Lansing, Michigan.
I think they started
in the early 1900s.
That would be cool like,
I've got an old roadster.
Yeah.
FRANK: On the front grill.
I'd love to stick
that on there, man.
Speedwagon.
MIKE: Even on the dash.
$75.
I don't know.
Here.
MICKEY: Yeah.
We probably sell it.
So probably, how about $90?
- $90?
Yeah.
How about $80?
MICKEY: Yes.
MIKE: All right, man.
- There you go.
Thank you.
I appreciate it.
I know, this was made for
an REO Speedwagon truck.
But I think this would be
cool on a hot rod or rat rod.
I could put this on a
1935 Ford panel truck.
To me, that's my speed wagon.
Guys got it?
Yeah.
All right, great.
MIKE: This property,
to anybody passing by,
is just an old building.
But to the Pile family,
it's their history.
They didn't want
to sell anything.
They're just not ready.
It's their forefathers
calling down
upon them saying, don't sell.
I could hear it as
soon as I walked in.
You got the flyer now.
So as you get
through the layers,
you find anything that's
not connected to the place,
give us a call.
- Give us a call.
We're not that far away.
We've been working
on this building
for the last five or six
years trying to clean it up.
It's something that
we want to keep alive.
That's something that we
want to instill in our kids.
They can say, hey, yeah, my
great, great, great, great,
great, grandpa started this.
- See you, Mickey.
See you, Isaac.
- Bye.
See you, fellows.